make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
the origin of the cultural phenomenon
that was Batman the animated series can
be traced back to a production meeting
held at Warner Brothers Studios sometime
in 1990 which was led by president of
animation gene mccurdy mccurdy was in
the beginning stages of her second
tenure at Warner Brothers having worked
as a vice president there in the early
1980s before leaving for hanna-barbera
where she oversaw the production of
successful shows such as the Smurfs and
the Flintstone kids after being rehired
by Warner Brothers in 1989 she said
about developing original animated
content for television bringing with her
several members of the team she'd worked
with at hanna-barbera
including writer Paul Dini the first
project mccurdy and Dini had worked on
was Tiny Toon Adventures a series
produced by legendary filmmaker Steven
Spielberg which focused on a new
generation of characters inspired by
classic Looney Tunes during this
production meeting McCarty revealed some
of the properties Wonder Brothers was
interested in developing into possible
television shows among these properties
was Batman who is enjoying a renewed
popularity thanks to the success of the
1989 Tim Burton directed Batman film the
idea of working on an animated Batman
series caught the attention of artists
Bruce Timm who was also present at the
production meeting Tim had a lengthy
resume as an artist and animator having
previously worked on he-man and the
Masters of the Universe for Filmation
and the Real Ghostbusters 4di see
entertainment Tim immediately went to
work developing character models for a
potential Batman series and when he
presented his designs to mccurdy the
next meeting she gave an enthusiastic
stamp of approval and put him to work on
creating a Batman animated short along
with background painter Eric Radomski
Tim and Radomski developed a minute and
a half long short to depict a Batman
thwarting an attempted jewelry robbery
and featured a cameo appearance by
Commissioner Jim Gordon mccurdy was so
impressed with the short as she put him
a Radomski in charge of developing an
entire series featuring the distinct
simplistic animation style in doing so
burst him set out to create an entire
series that would differ from the rest
of the cartoons in production at the
time and that it would appeal to not
only children but to adults as well
to do this an entire team of like-minded
creators needed to be assembled and so
another former hanna-barbera writer of
producer Alan Burnett joined the Batman
creative team Burnett had worked with DC
superheroes before as a writer on Super
Friends and had also written 50 episodes
of the Smurfs and worked on many of DC's
animated series in the 1990s before
coming to warner brothers
initially Burnett had no interest in
working on Batman because he'd been
frustrated with the strict standards and
practices that controlled cartoon
programming however after seeing the
shore that's him in Radomski had created
he became convinced that the Batman
series would be a faithful adaptation to
the character and agreed to go on board
also joining the team was writer Paul
Dini who'd worked with Tim on Tiny Toons
Dini had tried unsuccessfully to break
in a comic book writing in the past and
was eager to get to work on the Batman
project and so one of the first things
that Tim Burnett and Dini did along with
writer Mitch Bryan was develop a show
Bible or blueprint for the narrative and
a synthetic vision of the show that
would guide the production of future
episodes for his part Dini drew
inspiration from seminal Batman works
such as Frank Miller's Batman year one
and Alan Moore's The Killing Joke
Burnett was also committed to keeping
the show true to the essence of the
Batman mythos while at the same time
being fun for kids to watch which also
meant leaving out aliens and ghosts and
avoiding heavy social issues the team
soon added Shirley Walker a composer
who'd worked on the 1989 Batman film to
score each episode of the series a
practice that was practically unheard of
among animated series at the time and so
his Cassie began over 120 actors chosen
from a pool of 500 submitted recordings
were auditioned voice director Andrea
Romano had narrowed the pool down to
four actors but none of them quite
captured what she was looking for she
asked her roommate a casting director if
he knew any actors who would be good for
the role and he suggested a Juilliard
educated stage and soap opera actor
named Kevin Conroy
although Conway had never done any voice
acting up to that point Romano had
brought him in for an audition and was
blown away by Conway's work Bruce Timm
was also impressed citing the distinct
voices Conway had created for both
Batman and Bruce Wayne as one of the
factors that led to his selection for
the role
I am the knight and so once the team had
found their Batman
the next task was finding the right
voice for Batman's arch nemesis the
Joker
according to boost him the vast majority
of the applicants tried to emulate Cesar
Romero's portrayal in the 1966 Batman
television series starring Adam West
which was not what the showrunners had
in mind for the primary villain
eventually the team settled on Tim Curry
who was an experienced voice and film
actor but after recording a few episodes
they realized that curry did not fit
their vision and they began to consider
recasting at the same time the team was
way encouraged feature for the show
Warner Brothers was contacted by an
agent representing Mark Hamill Hamill
who was a huge fan of Batman was
interested in working on the show and
Romano created a small guest role for
him in one of the episodes where Hamill
recorded the episode he'd also made it
known that what he intended was to
become a permanent member of the cast
shortly thereafter Hamill was offered
the chance to audition for the role of
the Joker but he initially shied away
from playing such an iconic role and
expressed a desire to play one of
Batman's second tier villains such as
two-face or clay face Hamill also
thought that audiences would not buy
into the idea that the actor who
portrayed one of the best and known
loved heroes in film was now playing a
super villain however figuring that he
had little chance to actually land the
role the Joker Hamill relented an
audition
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
according to writer Paul Dini as soon as
Hamill perform the Joker's laugh which
captured the cruelty humour and sadness
of his character he knew that they'd
found the actor that was perfect for the
role and the decision was made to
replace curry with Hamill and so
following this other voice actors will
be added to the cast including future
Hellboy star Ron Perlman as Clayface and
Kate Mulgrew as red car the first
episode of batman the animated series
aired on the Fox Network block of
children's programming called Fox Kids
on September 5th and 1992 and aired in
the 4:30 p.m. timeslot on weekdays a
three months later Fox also began
running the show in primetime on Sunday
evenings but removed it from this
timeslot in March of 1993 as a failed to
garner the ratings they'd hoped for not
only was the show one of Fox's most
popular animated offerings among users
but is still widely regarded as the best
adaptation of Batman in any medium the
animation series contributed greatly to
the overall mythos of Batman in several
ways for example episode 3 titled heart
of ice focused on the villain mr. freeze
who was considered a lower tier member
of Batman's rogues gallery at the time
writer Paul Dini decided to expand on
freezes origin by introducing Nora the
wife of mr. freeze who become terminally
ill and who been placed in a cryogenic
chamber while he searched for a cure to
her condition mr. Freeze's boss shuts
down freezes research which effectively
ends any shot at survival for Nora after
freeze tries to exact revenge on his
boss he's eventually captured and taken
to Arkham Asylum and the episode ends
with free staring and a music box
belonging to his wife and apologizing
for failing her not only did Hart of
Iceland a great deal of gravitas to an
otherwise largely forgotten character
but it also won an Emmy for Outstanding
writing in an animated program and was
selected as the best episode of the
series by wizard magazine in 2005 and
truth the biggest contribution of the
animated series to Batman's mythos came
in episode 7 titled Joker's favor which
introduced a brand new villain to
Batman's rogues gallery in the form of
Harley Quinn Harley's character was
originally intended to be a one-off
cameo appearance as the showrunners
wanted to include a scene where someone
jumped out of a cake and captured a
group of police officers feeling the
Joker doing this would be out of
character they created a female sidekick
however both the creative team and fans
fell in love with Harley due to her
compelling aesthetic and the performance
of actress Arleen Sorkin
meaning that her character would be
expanded in some
and eventually incorporated into DC
Comics proper the first season of Batman
the Animated Series contains 65 episodes
and became a success in terms of both
critical response and ratings on March
3rd 1994 a second season premiered
featuring 20 episodes and Fox later made
the decision to stop airing the show
every weekday afternoon and instead air
at once per week as part of their
Saturday morning program the second
season featured Batman's sidekick Robin
were prominently than the first and was
subsequently retitled The Adventures of
Batman and Robin
on September 15 1995 the series
completed its original run with 85
episodes in total and most of the
creative team began working on their
next project Superman the animated
series in 1997 the contract granting Fox
exclusive rights to the show expired and
Warner Brothers approached Bruce Timm
and making more episodes of Batman to
run alongside Superman on one of others
own network the WB both Tim and Warner
executives wanted to give the show now
titled the new Batman adventures a new
feeling and Warner Brothers was
specifically focused on increasing the
show's appeal among young audiences
Tim's approach to the network's
objective was to modify the look of the
show to be more simplified and angular
and adding more of Batman supporting
cast such as Batgirl and Nightwing into
every episode this iteration of the show
ran for 24 episodes between September
13th 1997 and January 16th 1999 before
being replaced by Batman Beyond which
focused on an older Bruce Wayne
mentoring a new Batman named Terry
McGinnis in addition to being a critical
success in a rating smash on television
Batman the Animated Series expanded into
other media as well on Christmas Day 923
Warner Brothers released a full-length
animated feature titled Batman mask of
the phantasm into theaters mask of the
phantasm is considered by many fans to
be one of the best Batman movies to date
but it was not a success of the box
office earning six million dollars just
four hundred thousand over its 5.6
million dollar budget
the animated series also spawned a
comic-book tie-in to Batman adventures
which ran for a number of years in
addition to these endeavors Batman the
Animated Series also served as a
foundation and launching point for an
entire connected universe of animated
shows including Superman the animated
series Batman Beyond
Justice League and Justice League
Unlimited perhaps the best indication of
the legacy of Batman the Animated Series
lies not in its vast info
it's phenomenal critical reception
whether two Emmy Awards at garner but in
the fact that 25 years after the end of
its original run Batman the a minute
series continues to set the benchmark
for animated adaptations of coming up
with properties among fans who still
adore the show well into their adulthood
[Music]
[Music]